mr. Hemsworth what was your initial  impression of mr. Pratt we have a  picture here I want to refer to you this  is it one of your early meetings and I  don't know what this means what's  happening and by the way let's give it  up for our technology right here  [Music]  [Applause]  children's show has anything well I  noticed that he had a slight curvature  of the spine some scoliosis possibly so  I reached down to his lower right lumbar  spine and was checking that his discs  were in order and the noticeable  variation and it's probably why he has  referral of sciatic Danny's right leg so  that's you massaging the lower spine mr.  big revenue to us I don't know if that's  the picture of it on my ass it was there  from a minute yeah you look they're  smiling but you also look very  uncomfortable right face is definitely  knee deep in your Oh I'm just really  excited to take that home and put it  above my bedroom this is a here's to pee  this is yours to keep  you